hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show where it
is usually my job in the long-form
interviews to deconstruct world-class
performers of all different types to
tease out the routines habits favorite
books etc that you can apply to your own
lives this episode is going to be
something different it's an experimental
format that i'm super excited about i've
been thinking about it for a long time
and it really scratches an itch that
i've had for years i'm asked all the
time what are your favorite podcasts to
listen to and the fact of the matter is
i'm so busy with this podcast that i
don't always get to listen to what i
want to listen to right there's so many
great podcasts out there even when they
are by some of my closest friends so my
answer to this predicament was to ask
them to send me
one of their top segments each from
their podcast that i can listen to
and just as important also share with
you my dear listeners so my team edited
these together and here we are this
episode is a compilation of 15 to 30
minute clips from some of the best
podcasters in the world and certainly
some of my favorites and i told them
that these segments have to be valuable
as standalones so you will get value
from them at the beginning of each clip
you'll hear an intro from the host where
to find their work and podcast and so on
at the end i'll also share one of my
favorite clips from an episode of this
podcast the tim ferriss show from one of
the long form interviews
you will notice that the first host is
sam harris and he actually includes some
audio from his app the waking up app
which i asked for and i put him first
very very deliberately because i want to
give you all some of my favorite
meditations that you could listen to
repeatedly and to use this episode
basically as
a boot up mechanism or a reboot
mechanism when you're feeling stressed
or immersed in the chaos or just need
some perspective so that is why sam is
first so you can view this episode as a
buffet i strongly suggest you check out
the shows included and if you like my
podcast you will very likely enjoy the
featured shows in this episode for a
full list of the guests featured today
see the episode's description or as
usual head to tim.blog podcast for all
the details and before you go please let
me know what you think of this episode
what do you think of this format what
can we do to improve make it even better
let me know on twitter at t ferris
that's t-f-e-r-r-i-s-s
and if you can please cc at team tim
ferriss because that will also notify my
team who will want to keep an eye on
these things whether we continue this
series or not depends on you of course
i'm still going to do the long form
interviews that's going to be the meat
and potatoes of this podcast but i want
to experiment with different formats
because it is fun and i need to keep
this thing fun for me
with all that said please enjoy
this podcast episode is brought to you
by helix sleep
sleep is super important to me in the
last few years i've come to conclude it
is the end-all be-all that all good
things good mood good performance good
everything seem to stem from good sleep
so i've tried a lot to optimize and i've
tried pills and potions all sorts of
different mattresses you name it and for
the last few years i've been sleeping on
a helix midnight luxe mattress i also
have one in the guest bedroom and
feedback from friends has always been
fantastic it's something that they
comment on helix sleep has a quiz takes
about two minutes to complete that
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you with helix there's a specific
mattress for each and every body that is
your body also your taste so let's say
you sleep on your side and like a super
soft bed no problem or if you're a back
sleeper who likes a mattress that's as
firm as a rock they've got a mattress
for you too helix was selected as the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by gq magazine wired apartment
therapy and many others just go to
helixsleep.com
tim take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights risk free they'll even pick it up
from you if you don't love it and now my
dear listeners helix is offering up to
200 off of all mattress orders and two
free pillows at
helixsleep.com
tim these are not cheap pillows either
so getting two for free is an upgraded
deal so that's up to 200 off and two
free pillows at helixsleep.comtim
that's helix
h-e-l-i-x sleep dot com slash tim for up
to 200 off
so
check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
tim
this episode is brought to you by all
form if you've been listening to this
podcast for a while you've probably
heard me talk about helix sleep and
their mattresses which i've been using
since 2017. i have two of them upstairs
from where i'm sitting at this moment
helix has gone beyond the bedroom and
started making sofas they've launched a
company called all form
a-l-l-f-o-r-m and they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores so i'm
sitting in my living room right now and
it's entirely all form furniture i've
got two chairs i've got an ottoman and i
have an l sectional couch and i'll come
back to that you can pick your fabric
they're all spill stain and scratch
resistant the sofa color the color of
the legs the sofa size the shape to make
sure it's perfect for you and your home
also all form arrives in just three to
seven days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i was quite astonished by how
modular and easy these things fit
together kind of like lego pieces
they've got arm chairs love seats all
the way up to an eight seat sectional so
there's something for everyone you can
also start small and kind of build on
top of it if you want to get a smaller
couch and then build out on it which is
actually in a way what i did because i
can turn
my l-sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman in a matter of about 60 seconds
it's pretty rad so i mentioned i have
all these different things in this room
i use the natural leg finish which is
their lightest color and i dig it i mean
i've been using these things hours and
hours and hours every single day so
i am using what i am sharing with you
guys and if getting a sofa without
trying it in store sounds risky you
don't need to worry all form sofas are
delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping and you get 100 days
to decide if you want to keep it that's
more than three months and if you don't
love it they'll pick it up for free and
give you a full refund your sofa frame
also has a forever warranty that's
literally forever so check it out take a
look they've got all sorts of cool stuff
to choose from i was skeptical and it
actually worked it worked much better
than i could have imagined and i'm very
very happy so to find your perfect sofa
check out
allform.com tim that's a-l-l-f-o-r-m dot
com slash tim all form is offering
twenty percent off all orders to you my
dear listeners at allform.com
tim make sure to use the code tim at
checkout that's allforum.com
[Music]
hello tim ferriss fans this is sam
harris
i've been on this podcast a couple of
times before and i'm also a frequent
listener
i host my own podcast making sense
and i also have an app called waking up
which i previewed here on tim's podcast
about three years ago
and it's been a major focus of mine ever
since
as some of you might remember my
academic background is in neuroscience
and philosophy
i also share tim's interest in
psychedelics both in the current
scientific research and in the
occasional personal use
i've also spent a lot of time practicing
various forms of meditation
when i was an undergraduate i became
interested in esoteric things like the
nature of consciousness and the nature
of the self both on what we can
understand about them philosophically
and scientifically and in what could
only be discovered about them through
direct experience
and at that point i dropped out of
school
for what became a full decade i made
many trips to india and nepal where i
got a chance to study with some of the
greatest meditation teachers who were
alive at that time
this was in the late 80s and 90s i also
spent about two years on silent retreats
ranging length from one week to three
months
i eventually did go back to school where
i finished my degree in philosophy and
then i did a phd in neuroscience
and while i've covered many other areas
in my work since
i've written several books and done
hundreds of podcast episodes on a wide
range of topics
i've always been most interested in
those first questions about the nature
of mind that sent me to asia in the
first place and into the silence of
retreat
while questions about consciousness and
the nature of the self may seem divorced
from everyday concerns they actually
relate directly to the most fundamental
causes of happiness and suffering and to
the larger question of what it means to
live a good life
personally psychologically
ethically and even collectively for
whole societies
waking up is where i fully explore these
issues
and tim has invited me to give you a
sampling of some of the content that can
be found there
so here are a few lessons and short
reflections that are fairly
representative of the kinds of things i
talk about there
there are also many other teachers and
scholars on waking up and the app is
always growing but i've just included
samples of my own content here
anyway i hope you find this useful
enjoy
i'd like you to take a moment to think
about all the things in this life
that you will experience for the last
time
of course there will come a day when you
will die
and then everything will have been done
for the last time
but
long before you die
you will cease to have certain
experiences
experiences that you surely take for
granted now
if you're a parent
when is the last time
you will pick up your child
or tuck her into bed
or read her a story
our youngest daughter still says aminals
instead of animals and though i'm a
stickler for words
i'm not correcting her
each one of those
is priceless
now thinking in this way lends a
poignancy to everything
even to things that you don't like
again let's say you're a new parent and
you're getting woken up several times a
night by your baby
that's brutal
but there will be a last time
and knowing that
can change your experience in the moment
there's something sweet even about this
experience
it's possible that you will miss this
we do everything a finite number of
times
and yet we tend to take even beautiful
moments for granted
and the rest of the time we're just
trying to get through stuff
you're just trying to get to the end of
whatever experience you're having
tim urban who writes this wonderful blog
titled wait but why
often touches this topic
he actually publishes a poster which
represents 90 years of life in weeks
each line has 52 squares and there are
90 lines on a single page
and the scale is frankly
a little alarming to contemplate
each week is a significant piece of 90
years
and you can put your finger on the
current week in your life
you can see where you are and then of
course you realize you have no assurance
of how many weeks you have left
assuming that you have 90 years
certainly 90 good years
is generally not a safe assumption
what you can know however
is that each time you do something
pleasant or unpleasant
that is one last time you will do it
and there will come a time when you will
have done something the final time
and you will rarely know when that is
for instance i used to love to ski and i
now haven't skied in well over a decade
will i ever ski again
i have no idea but i can assure you that
the last time i took off my skis
i was not even dimly aware of the
possibility that it might be the last
time
right that i might live for many many
more years and yet this stood a good
chance of being the last time i would
ever ski
when is the last time you swam in the
ocean
or went camping
when is the last time you took a walk
just to take a walk
as you go about your day today consider
everything you're doing
is like this
everything
represents a finite opportunity
to savor your life
on some level everything is precious
and if it doesn't seem that way
i think you'll find that paying more
attention
can make it seem that way
attention
really is
your true source of wealth even more
than time
right because you can waste time
being distracted
so this is just to urge you to take a
little more care
when you meet someone for the first time
and you shake their hand
pay a little more attention
when you thank somebody for something
mean it a little more
connect with your life
and mindfulness is the tool that allows
you to do that
because the only alternative is to be
lost in thought
and every time you notice that you're
lost that you're distracted by a thought
about the past or the future
and you come back
you are training your mind
and it may feel like an effort at first
but eventually it's like continually
waking up from a dream
and ask yourself
how much effort
does that take
many people who are at first skeptical
about the benefits of meditation
find their skepticism relieved when they
hear that meditation changes the brain
and there are areas of the brain that
appear to physically change size in
response to meditation
undoubtedly new connections are made and
others are diminished
and in addition to structural changes
there are functional ones
and there does seem to be a more or less
linear relationship between changes of
this kind and the amount of time a
person is spent practicing
now this information is interesting and
i will certainly discuss it in other
contexts
but the truth is
virtually anything you do
changes your brain
the fact that you had breakfast this
morning
and that you can remember it
changed your brain
and of course learning any complex skill
requires that your brain physically
alter its structure that is what
learning is
at the level of the brain
so saying that meditation changes the
brain
is not to say that it's special
or that it's good for you
most things that are bad for you also
change your brain
of course there's a growing literature
on the benefits of meditation
but i want to suggest that there's
nothing
likely to appear in that literature that
represents the deepest reason why one
should meditate
for instance there are studies that
suggest that meditation improves immune
function
or reduces stress
or that is associated with less
age-related thinning of the cerebral
cortex
well having a good immune system
and reducing stress
and not suffering neurodegeneration
are good things in general but
those studies might fail to replicate
tomorrow
and should that happen my
recommendations in this course would not
change at all
there really are deeper reasons to
meditate and to live an examined life in
general
meditation is a skill that opens doors
that you might not otherwise know exist
and to say that you should do this
because it reduces stress
or confers any other ancillary benefit
it's really to miss the point
consider an analogy to reading
is reading good for you
does it reduce stress
do you see what's peculiar about that
framing
given how profound the difference is
between being an avid reader and being
illiterate
these are strange questions
just think about it
does reading reduce stress
it sort of depends on what you read
right
is it good for you
well i think we can all imagine
scenarios where it's not good for
somebody in any kind of straightforward
way
but
reading is one of the most important
skills our species has ever acquired
almost everything we care about depends
on it
of course mindfulness is a very
different sort of skill
but it also has sweeping implications
the other way to think about this is
that you are always meditating on
something
your attention is always bound up in
something
we largely become what we pay attention
to
we are building our minds
in each moment we're building habits and
desires
and worries
and expectations
and prejudices
and insights
and mindfulness is just the ability to
notice this process with clarity and to
then prioritize
what you pay attention to
why not pay attention to those things
that make you a better person
why not free your attention from all of
the trivial things
that are clamoring for it
let's say you pick up your phone to
check your email
and at that moment your five-year-old
daughter starts telling you a story
now several things are possible
you could be so lost in your thoughts
about your email
and you could find the urge to respond
to it so compelling that you don't even
notice that your daughter is talking to
you or you could notice it only to
rebuff her in a way that makes her feel
terrible
and you might be so entranced
that five minutes later you wouldn't
even recall that this episode occurred
that's how most people live their lives
in fact that's how most of us live most
of our lives even after we learn to
meditate
but the more you train in this practice
the more degrees of freedom you'll find
in situations like this
you can notice for instance that your
daughter is trying to get your attention
and that giving her your attention
is in competition with your following
this urge to check your email
and when actual mindfulness comes online
you can feel the urge to check your
email as a pattern of energy in your
body
and simply let it go
that is you can actually break the link
between the feeling
and the behavioral imperative it seems
to communicate
it's true that one way to get rid of
this feeling is to check your email but
another is to simply let go of it
and only mindfulness allows you to do
the latter
and then you can direct your attention
to the five-year-old who is standing in
front of you and it might be the only
story she tells you that day
and you can be aware of this fact in
that moment
you can feel the poignancy of that
and in that moment you can further
ingrain this new habit
you can become the kind of person
who is fully present in moments like
that and you become that kind of person
not just for yourself
by changing your brain
but in this case for your daughter
by changing her brain
and this is just a 30 second slice of
life
when you learn to meditate
there are literally hundreds
even thousands
of moments like this throughout the day
these are choice points that wouldn't
otherwise exist
these are paths taken and not taken
for good reason
but without free attention
there's no place for good reasons to
land
and as you grow in mindfulness you begin
to notice the lies you can no longer
tell
and you begin to have insights into your
true motives in various situations that
are sometimes not flattering
but you want these insights all the same
because how else could you become a
better person
that is what it is to live an examined
life
so
don't meditate just because it's good
for you
it's more important than that
when you sit down to meditate
you will find yourself assailed by
thoughts
thoughts about what you need to do later
in the day
thoughts about things that worry you
thoughts about things you want
or don't want
the moment you attempt to pay attention
to your breath
or to the sound of the wind in the trees
you will meet your mind
and your mind
is the most rambling
chaotic
needling
insulting
insufferable person
you will ever meet
it's like having some maniac walk
through the front door of your house
and follow you from room to room
and refuse to stop talking and this
happens every day of your life
it is possible to get him to stop
talking for brief periods of time
and that can come with greater
concentration in meditation
it's possible to pay attention to the
breath for instance
and to be so focused on it
that thoughts no longer arise
and this can be an extremely pleasant
experience
when it happens
but it's a temporary experience
real relief
comes when we recognize thoughts for
what they are
mere appearances in consciousness
images
bits of language
the fact that a thought has arisen
does not give it a necessary claim upon
your life
it need not have any implications
psychological or otherwise
of course you'll continue to think
and to be moved to act by thoughts
but meditation gives you a choice
do you really want to follow this next
thought
wherever it leads
there's a story from
2012 i think
but i only recently stumbled on it
online
about a woman who was on a tour bus in
iceland and at one point when the bus
stopped
near a scenic canyon
rest stop
she got off and decided to change her
clothes and when she returned to the bus
nobody recognized her so when it came
time to leave
many people grew concerned that the
woman in her original likeness was
missing
and they told the driver that an asian
woman in dark clothes
had not yet returned to the bus
and apparently the woman in question
didn't recognize this description of
herself
and so
she too became concerned about the
missing traveler and a search party was
quickly formed and she joined it and the
search apparently went on all day and
into the night
and the police were notified and the
coast guard was notified too
and they even readied a helicopter for
use in the morning
and it wasn't until 3 am that the woman
finally realized
that she was the missing person
and of course the search was called off
now this is obviously a quite crazy and
comical situation
but we're actually in a similar position
with respect to our own minds
because we spend our lives seeking
and the goal of our search is poorly
defined
we get inducted into a search by our
culture
by the expectations that others place on
us and which we learn to place on
ourselves
and we learn that there are things we
want out of life largely because others
want them
we want to succeed in various ways
rather than fail
and we need to acquire skills to do this
and we want all the social advantages
that come with success
we want others to respect us
why we want this is never really
inspected it goes without saying
this is something we crave
of course various sources of danger and
disappointment seem to lurk everywhere
and however much we succeed
things naturally fall apart
everything needs to be shored up against
the forces of entropy and the landscape
continues to shift
expectations change
cultures like a vast tide that keeps
sweeping everything out toward a horizon
that we can't clearly see
i mean where is all this going
what will life be like in 10 years
think of everything that captures your
attention
the things you buy
or wish you could buy
how you dress
and all the preferences that are
enshrined there in your closet
your exercise routine your relationship
to sleep
your diet
consider all your efforts to improve
these things
or to maintain them or to reconsider
them and of course all the while you
hope to have whatever fun you can have
while making these efforts right to
entertain yourself socially or binge
watch the latest series on netflix
you're continually in motion
as a matter of attention it's just one
damn thing after the next then
occasionally something big happens
somebody close to you dies say
and you have a moment to reflect on the
whole spectacle of what is otherwise
normal
and you might think what is the point of
all of this
what am i up to
really
now i'm not saying the details of life
don't matter
it's not that fun
doesn't matter or work or money or
clothing there are countless transitory
sources of satisfaction
and if we have our priorities straight
these are ranked in a hierarchy of sorts
at least implicitly and we spend our
time and attention in ways that are
proportionate to what we actually value
now
we might be lying to ourselves about
what our hierarchy actually is for
instance i might believe that my kids
are the most important thing in the
world to me
but if that's true they should get more
of my time and attention than my
following college football does
it's against this background of seeking
satisfaction
amid ceaseless change that you can see
how radical an act meditation actually
is
meditation is the act of calling off the
search
it is the art of doing nothing
but we should be clear about what it
means to do nothing because it actually
matters what sort of nothing one is
doing
for instance you can just space out and
make no mental effort at all
and then you'll naturally be lost in
thought just daydreaming now this is
actually our default state when we're
not explicitly paying attention to
something or trying to get something
done
in fact it's our default state even when
we're doing many things that do require
our attention
like driving a car
thoughts just keep coming and we keep
thanking them for better or worse
and if you pay attention to the
character of your thoughts
you'll find that you're mostly talking
to yourself about all the things you
want to do or wish you had done to
become happy
you're continuously narrating the search
so that's not quite the doing nothing
we're after
when one first begins to meditate the
practice
seems like it requires effort it doesn't
seem like you're doing nothing you're
actually struggling to pay attention
to the breath for instance or to other
sensations in your body or to sounds or
even to thoughts themselves and the
struggle is to sustain one's mindfulness
for any significant amount of time
without being lost in thought
and it's true this apparent struggle
continues for quite some time
but once you know how to meditate you
discover that
real mindfulness
is free of effort
it too simply appears
like anything else
the clouds part all on their own
and you just notice the next thing you
notice and you can even try to practice
this way from the beginning and rather
than strategically pay attention to an
object of meditation like the breath
you can practice what's often called
choiceless awareness where you just
notice whatever you notice without
making an effort to stay focused on any
specific object
but this isn't quite doing nothing
either
there's still this fluctuation
this feeling of being lost and found
this game of cat and mouse with
attention
and there can still be this subtle or
not so subtle sense of seeking to get
somewhere
and the sense that there's a self that
is doing the seeking
the only way of truly doing nothing
is to recognize how consciousness always
already is
open
unobstructed
effortlessly aware of its apparent
changes
you have to recognize what you would
otherwise seek
the very context of any effort you could
make
to pay attention
you have to turn about
and realize
that nothing is or can be
lost
think of that woman on the bus
the moment before she realized that she
was the object of the search
she's looking for a lost tourist
and think of that next moment when she
suddenly realizes
that she is the one
who has been presumed lost
now is it accurate to say that she has
now found herself
was the search ever fulfilled
no
there was a false premise that had been
unrecognized
just think of how the sense of seeking
evaporated in her case
the recognition of consciousness
reveals that the contents of
consciousness
are beside the point
and all seeking is an effort to improve
or to maintain or to otherwise modify
the contents of consciousness
so the freedom
that you find in meditation
is not a change
in experience really
it's the recognition
of the context of experience itself
you simply need to drop back and
recognize the condition
in which everything is already appearing
thoughts and intentions
and moods
and emotions
sensations perceptions
everything
is simply appearing
as a matter of experience there is no
you
apart
from this flow
so the real way of doing nothing
isn't to stop doing anything
it's simply to recognize that everything
is already happening
on its own
take a moment to close your eyes
and become aware of your body
as a field of sensation
all at once
you don't need to take time
to do this
and notice your tendency to establish
your point of view
in your head
noticing the rest of your body
as though from above
see if you can recognize
that from the point of view of
consciousness
there is no
above
or below
or inside
or outside
everything that appears
is simply appearing
in consciousness
as a modification
of it
as a matter of experience
awareness is not in your head
and it can't be aimed from your head
toward other objects of perception
or sensation
or emotion
or thought
everything is simply appearing
in its own place
all by itself
just as the sky
need not make any effort to contain
or open to
the clouds
notice that consciousness itself
need not do
anything
it's simply the condition
in which everything appears
including the sense of having a head
including every movement of attention
and you're not aware
of
this condition
you're aware as it
when we practice meditation one of the
things we learn is how to begin again in
each moment
you notice that you're distracted you've
been lost in thought for who knows how
long and then suddenly you return to a
clear witnessing
of the contents of consciousness
you notice a sound
or the breath
or some other sensations in your body
where you see the present thought itself
unraveling
and in this clear noticing
of this next appearance in consciousness
we're training our minds
we're practicing a willingness to simply
return to the present moment
without judgment
without disappointment
without contraction
with a mind that is standing truly free
of the past
and it's always possible to recover this
freedom
no matter what happens
let's say you notice you're distracted
and rather than just observe the next
sound or sensation
you're immediately plunged into
self-judgment you're annoyed
you subscribe to this damn app and
you're supposed to be meditating but you
just spent the last five minutes
thinking about something that you saw on
television last night
but you can break this spell and begin
again at any point
by just noticing self-judgment and
frustration as appearances
and the truth is they're as good as
anything else you can notice when it
comes to revealing the intrinsic freedom
of consciousness
it's openness
it's centerlessness
it's selflessness
honestly frustration real frustration
a mind like a clenched fist
is just as good as the breath
or a sound or even an expansive emotion
like joy
if you'll just drop back and recognize
what consciousness is like in that
moment
now this ability to begin again
has ethical force as well
it's actually the foundation of
forgiveness
the only way to truly forgive another
person or oneself
is to restart the clock in the present
and this habit of mind allows for a
resilience that we can't otherwise find
and there are literally hundreds of
opportunities each day to practice it
if you notice that a conversation with a
friend or a family member or a colleague
isn't going very well or you're not
having fun at a party
or you've been trying to get some work
done
but you found that you've just wasted
the last hour on the internet
or you're working out in the gym but you
haven't been making much of an effort
the moment you notice
this ghost of mediocrity hovering over
the present
you can
fully exercise it just by beginning
again
and then fully commit by relinquishing
the past
there's no real reason why the next 10
minutes in the gym
can't be the best you've had in years
there's no real reason why you can't put
this conversation
that's almost over on a new footing by
saying something that is truly useful
so the practice is to stop telling
ourselves a story about what has been
happening
and to fully connect with experience in
this moment
notice this present thought
this fear
this judgment
this doubt this desire to be elsewhere
as an appearance in consciousness
and then
just begin again
okay
well that was a sample of a few lessons
from the waking up app
for those of you who might want to
locate this content on the app what you
heard were the lessons titled
the last time
don't meditate because it's good for you
the veil of thought the art of doing
nothing
and begin again
it was also a moment thrown in there
moments are short reflections from 30
seconds to 2 minutes in length that
arrive once or twice a day if you have
your notifications turned on
generally speaking the aim of waking up
isn't to just help you meditate
is to help you live a more examined and
fulfilling life altogether
and to that end there's no shortage of
resources you can explore in the app now
including dozens of conversations i've
had with philosophers and scholars and
contemplatives there are other courses
with some of the best meditation
teachers around
and their discussions about psychedelics
and sleep and happiness and stoicism and
effective altruism
and much more
we recently added the full catalogue of
alan watts's talks too
which are great fun
the app does require a subscription but
it's also free for anyone who can't
afford it and we give a minimum of 10 of
our profits to the most effective
charities and we're actively looking for
ways to encourage individuals and
businesses to join us in doing that
this has been directly inspired by the
work on effective altruism being done by
the philosopher will mccaskill who i
actually first discovered here on tim's
podcast
it's amazing how much that one episode
of this podcast has affected my life and
subsequently the lives of many others
i don't know if you followed that tim
but my further conversations with will
have raised many millions of dollars for
give well in other charities
so thanks for that
anyway if you want more information
about waking up everything can be found
at wakingup.com
as always tim thanks for what you do
in addition to counting myself among
your friends i'm a huge fan of the
conversations you have here
and thanks for the opportunity to speak
to your audience once again
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
ag-1 by athletic greens if you're
traveling if you're just busy if you're
not sure if your meals or where they
should be it covers your bases with
approximately 75 vitamins minerals and
whole foods source ingredients you'll be
hard-pressed to find a more
nutrient-dense formula on the market it
has a multivitamin multi-mineral greens
complex probiotics and prebiotics for
gut health and immunity formula
digestive enzymes and adaptogens you get
the idea right now athletic greens is
giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
tim
hi my name is peter atiyah and what
you're about to hear are a few clips
from my podcast the peter attila drive
the drive is a deep dive podcast
focusing on maximizing longevity and all
that goes into that from a physical
cognitive and emotional standpoint as
far as my background i'm a physician
focusing on the applied science of
longevity what does that mean it means
that i take care of patients and i try
to figure out the best way to take the
science of longevity and apply it in a
clinical fashion using all the levers at
our disposal such as nutrition exercise
sleep emotional and mental health and
pharmacology to increase lifespan that's
kind of how long you live part well
equally if not more importantly
improving health span the how well you
live the clips you're about to listen to
feature part of an episode where i speak
about a number of things including
cancer and heart disease and also
something called apob for those of you
that don't know what apob is i'll
explain it in much more detail but it's
something that everybody should know
their own value of it's probably the
single most important biomarker when it
comes to managing your risk of
cardiovascular disease which is of
course the number one killer in the
world
i also talk in these clips at length
about time restricted feeding the
importance of protein and of course my
favorite subject of them all exercise if
you like this clip and you want to hear
more you can find my podcast on any
podcast platform or you can visit our
site
peteratiammd.com atiya is spelt att ia
you can also find me on youtube
instagram twitter or facebook though i
probably spend more time on instagram
than all the others
under the id petermd
anything
that you think is really interesting
under cancer i think on cancer is just
my complete
aggression when it comes to screening
for gastrointestinal cancers let's just
kind of put big big things in
perspective how many cancer deaths do we
have
each year so i think for 2020 we're
looking at probably 600 000 people in
the u.s died of cancer
and how many of those were in the
digestive system
170 000 of the 600 000 so the gi system
is a really big issue right and that's
basically everything from mouth to anus
now some of those things are very
difficult to screen for so pancreatic
cancer we don't really have a great way
to screen for it and that's why
we use things like diffusion weighted
image mris liquid biopsies
as ways to basically pursue those things
now we have a podcast that's coming up
on liquid biopsies and all things around
that so that's going to be a very
interesting podcast we had a previous
podcast that was probably on the first
hundred with raj uttarwala where we
talked about diffusion imaging mri for
cancer screening so if we put those
things aside the good news is that there
are a lot of cancers
for which we can directly take a look at
the epithelial surface that is going to
become cancerous and there is no part of
that
that is
more important than the colon so
the esophagus the stomach and the colon
probably represent
i don't know
40 percent
of those gi cancers
so again liver and intra hepatic bile
duct and pancreas are probably also
about 40 and those are much harder to
screen but
when you look at organ specific sites
colon cancer is generally in the top
three leading causes of death for both
men and women
and what i'm about to say is going to
sound incredibly bold and controversial
it seems increasingly true to me which
is nobody should ever die from colon
cancer and i would add the same for
esophageal and stomach and the reason
for that is
especially in colon the progression from
non-cancer to cancer is visible to the
naked eye through the transition of
non-malignant polyp to malignant polyp
so if you did this as a thought
experiment
if you did a colonoscopy on somebody
every single day of their life
they would never get colon cancer
because at some point you would see the
polyp you would remove it while it is
non-cancerous and they would not get
cancer so of course how do you turn that
thought experiment into a real life idea
well you have to ask the question
what is the shortest interval of time
for which a person can have a completely
normal colonoscopy until they can have a
cancer
there's no clear answer to this question
and we've done a lot of work on it and
i've spoken with a lot of
gastroenterologists about it and there
are certainly some case reports that it
can happen in as little as six to eight
months
of course one has to question whether in
fact
people
had perfectly normal colonoscopies six
to eight months earlier
and it's possible that they did not and
that something was actually missed at
the time
but i think most people would agree that
if you had a colonoscopy every
one to two years
the likelihood that you could ever
develop a colon cancer while maybe not
zero is so remote that you could
effectively take colon cancer off the
list of the top 10 reasons why someone
dies of cancer and so it's for that
reason
that i'm very aggressive when it comes
to this type of screening which also
includes upper endoscopy so you
basically get for free the esophagus and
stomach when you look at the entire
colon rectum anus
and what are your costs well your costs
are obviously the dollar cost which is
not cheap i can't tell you what the
average cost of a colonoscopy i think
when i get them done because
i'm getting them done outside of regular
screening so i'm paying for them they're
certainly not cheap i want to say maybe
i'm paying 2 000 for a colonoscopy so
that's a huge cost and then there's
obviously the risk of the sedation which
again is not zero in the hands of
someone who's doing this every minute of
every day it's very small and then of
course there's the risk of perforation
which again is also incredibly small
especially in a healthy individual and
even if it does happen it's generally
something that's pretty easy to manage
so again is this something that i'm
taking lightly no it's not and i can't
tell you yet what the ideal frequency is
because at some point for example a
colonoscopy every day would be a silly
idea on all of those metrics right your
risk of complication is clearly going to
exceed your risk of cancer
notwithstanding the cost and daily
challenges of bowel preps so where is
that number i don't know but it's much
more frequently than what's being done
today that's what i would propose it's
not every five to ten years so it's
probably every one to three years would
be my intuition
another good resource on this is
after chadwick boseman passed away we
did a weekly email on it and we'll link
to it in the show notes it's called
colorectal cancer screening and i think
the other thing that was talked about in
there which you do a little different is
not only the frequency but the age in
which you start your patients for their
first colonoscopy
i think
the
standard is 50 or 45 now but either way
you prefer
much earlier i think they are moving it
down i mean in our practice we think 40
is the age at which a person should have
their first colonoscopy if they have no
history of colon cancer about when i had
my first one was 40 or 41.
i'm 49 right now and i'm scheduled for a
colonoscopy in a month and that'll
probably be my fourth one
and to be clear
this requires me arguing a little bit
with my primary care physician who's
saying peter you're being a bit
ridiculous but then i say look i want
you to go and read what i've written
about this let's hop on a call and let's
discuss this
in the end he's like okay and then you
could argue well maybe i get my way
because i'm a doctor and i can be more
persuasive in my arguments but i think
these are the discussions patients need
to be having with their doctors if
they're in a position that they can
afford to do this outside of their
regular screening and if not i think
they should push to see whatever can be
done with inside the bounds of their
insurance as well
i realize that we're all tainted by our
biases
but the images of the people that i have
seen who have had colony cancer before
the age of 50. i mean those are seared
into my brain
and that's why i think those are just
such asymmetric
benefits i think you had a few other
things and diseases that you mentioned
early on yeah so on ascbd
i've also become far more aggressive
on the timing and magnitude of apob
reduction so
take a step back and ask what are the
leading
causes
or modifiable causes of ascvd the big
three
are pretty unambiguously smoking
hypertension and hyper beta
lipoproteinemia which is just a really
fancy word for saying too many
lipoproteins that have apob on them so
that's ldl
idl vldl lp little a
by measuring apob why i'm such a fan of
measuring apo b as opposed to just
measuring lp
ldl particle number or ldl cholesterol
number
is we have one single number that
captures the total concentration of apob
and while that's pretty well associated
with non-hdl cholesterol which is a far
better surrogate than ldl cholesterol
it's still better and that's been
demonstrated and i think we even covered
that in a previous podcast
where we went over the discordance
between
non-hdl cholesterol and apob
so now the question becomes well
when should you start apob reduction and
how much should you lower it and i'll
tell you i used to take a point of view
that if a 40 year old had an elevated
apo b
let's just put some numbers to this
right so
the 20th percentile of apo b is about
80 milligrams per deciliter
i used to say that let's say somebody
was at the 50th percentile they're 40
years old their calcium score is zero
and they were ambivalent about lipid
lowering therapy and let's assume that
they're not insulin resistant and you've
done all the things that you can do
reasonably with nutrition
i wouldn't push that hard i've now taken
a very different stand which is i've
basically taken the stand with others
that i've taken with myself which is
the evidence is overwhelming
that infantile levels of apob are not
deleterious in any way meaning an apob
of 30 to 40 milligrams per deciliter
which is the level that children would
have poses not only no risk to children
as evidenced by the fact that
i mean that doesn't require an
explanation
but as evidenced by what we see in
the literature on adults with levels
that have been pharmacologically reduced
tells me that we need to be lower and
the amount of time it takes to see a
benefit tells me we don't want to wait
until there's an issue in other words if
the
reason we begin therapy is because
somebody has a positive calcium score
which again we covered this in great
detail
in
is that ama come out yet i was just
gonna say that ama will be released two
weeks after this oh okay okay yeah so
for people listening we have a dedicated
ascvd ama which goes into heavy detail
for about 90 minutes on all this stuff
where if this is
of interest hang on for a few weeks and
we'll be diving even deeper into it yeah
i get a bit lost with the recording
cycle but that's a great ama that goes
super deep
on
basically all of the reasons why i think
my point of view now is treat early and
treat aggressively and i will now also
make a very bold statement again it's
let's start with the thought experiment
right if the thought experiment
for colon cancer was do a colonoscopy
every day on a person's life starting at
the age of 30
would you eliminate colon cancer deaths
i think the answer is yes and similarly
i would say
pharmacologically lower apob
to somewhere in the 20 to 30 milligram
per deciliter range for everybody in the
population
while someone is in their 20s can you
eliminate ascvd and i think the answer
is probably yes
in other words i think what you're
basically going to do is
eliminate death from atherosclerotic
causes
and that would need to be
started in 20s i think so yeah very
early on yeah so again how do you take
that thought experiment and turn it into
a practical implication because i don't
think it's practical to take every 20
year old
and obliterate their apob although it's
clearly something we do
in the subset of patients
who have
significant genetic abnormalities such
as the cluster of genetic abnormalities
that coalesce around a condition called
familial hypercholesterolemia
we certainly do medicate those patients
usually as teenagers so this is not some
completely crazy idea but i think
practically what it means is
basically by the time you're in your
late 30s or early 40s if you have any
measure of apo b that's even north of
the 20th percentile that should be
completely lowered so in some ways i
would view an apo b ceiling of
60 as the limit and that's probably at
about the fifth percentile you sort of
want everybody to be
below the fifth percentile
do you know the rough numbers of twenty
percent
fifty percent and eighty percent apob
just for people who maybe have their apo
b metrics
down but they don't know where it
relates in the percentage
yeah so fifth percentile from the
framingham offspring study was is 62. i
just in my mind keep keep 60. 10th
percentile is about 70
20th percentiles 78 so i just think of
80 50th percentiles about 100 it's
technically 97 80th percentile 118 so i
just kind of think of 120
95th percentile is 140. yeah i mean
we're going to see patients of all these
levels i've got a new patient whose
first labs i'm reviewing very soon i
just got his labs back
the other day his zapo b is i don't know
i want to say like 171.
and the 95th percentile is 140 so he's
you know in the 99.9 percentile he
almost meets diagnostic criteria for fh
based on his ldl cholesterol but you're
going to see the whole spectrum here but
again going back to this point
i just don't see a reason to have an apo
b ever north of 60 milligrams per
deciliter and i think when you look at a
lot of the mendelian randomizations plus
the clinical trial data
if you have an ldl cholesterol
below
30 or an apob
below
40 milligrams per deciliter
for a very long period of time i think
the odds that you're going to suffer a
cvd
are incredibly low again the earlier you
start in the lower you go the more you
can make that number approximate zero
and therefore it then only becomes a
question of what are your therapeutic
choices to get there how do you do this
in a way that minimizes the side effects
of that because for some people to lower
apob that much
is trivial like in me it's actually
really easy i take a pcsk9 inhibitor and
i take a statin and i can basically
eradicate it and i don't have any issues
with either of those
but for some people statins are
difficult to tolerate about five percent
of the population has intractable muscle
soreness and that appears to be the case
regardless of which statin you use and
we tend to
rotate through different statins i like
to start with reservostatin or
pravastatin
and then if we have difficulties there
move to patavastatin or livolo but if
people can't tolerate any of those
things today we have so many other
options if they're a hyper absorber we
would use ezetimibe
if they're a hypersynthesizer but can't
respond to statins we use methanoic acid
so we have lots of tools up our sleeve
today more than ever before and that's
why i just think we should be more and
more aggressive on this now
yeah i mean
you could say it's even a more bold
statement too because
listening to that alan snyderman podcast
and just how many doctors especially in
the us don't even look at apob so the
importance for people listening to this
too is when they go to their doctor and
they're going to run their labs just
making sure to bring up is it possible
to get an apo b ram because if they just
do what a typical cholesterol panel or a
typical annual exam it might not even be
looked at
yep
moving to our next category
anything on
nutrition that you specifically want to
bring up or talk about
yeah i think there are two things on the
nutrition front that are worth talking
about where i've become more pointed in
my feelings over the past roughly two
years which i guess would be over the
last hundred episodes
so the first is my view that
i think most of the benefit of
time-restricted feeding
is accrued through caloric restriction
so
i've always been a little
unsure
of how much of the time restriction was
exerting its benefit through factors
that go beyond
what is likely a reduced calorie intake
in someone with a smaller feeding window
so in other words was there something
magical about not eating so if you had
an experiment that was done where
people are going to eat 3 000 calories a
day spread out over the course of 12
hours versus people that are going to
eat 3 000 calories spread out over 6
hours is there any difference between
them and i think the answer today is no
i think the answer is
nope when people talk about how
time-restricted feeding is helping them
lose weight and manage insulin
resistance and things like that i think
it appears that that's all due to
reduced caloric intake it's just harder
to eat more during a narrower window and
at some point that window gets narrow
enough that it's almost impossible to
eat as much as you would in the course
of a day unless you're deliberately
being as gluttonous as possible and i've
seen people attempt to do that for
reasons i don't understand
and i think
where this gets problematic
is in people who can't really afford to
lose too much muscle
and not completely atypical trf scenario
i see is in a patient who
becomes completely obsessed with
only eating in a six hour window or even
less
and
at the end of a year they've lost five
pounds so they were kind of normal-ish
weight to begin with you know they were
180 pounds to begin with and they're
511s pretty normal
and a year later they're 175 and they're
like this is just amazing i've lost 5
pounds i feel like i can eat whatever i
want
then you do a dexa scan on them and you
realize well
you lost 10 pounds of lean tissue
and you gained 5 pounds of fat mass so
yes you're down 5 pounds
but your body fat is actually up i'm
making this up because i'd have to do
the math but your body fat's up three
percent your visceral fat is up by 500
grams
nothing has moved in the right direction
except this very very crude measurement
of the number on the scale in these
individuals i think because they're
eating
so much less protein
they're impairing muscle protein
synthesis so they're actually losing
lean mass even while putting on fat mass
they're oftentimes becoming insulin
resistant i especially see this in
people who are doing one meal a day this
the so-called omad especially because
most people who are doing that are doing
it late in the day and so now they're
having
[Music]
impaired glucose homeostasis
overnight we're seeing high glucose
levels overnight probably high cortisol
levels and impaired glucose tolerance in
the morning so
a lot of these things just
aren't what we would want to see now
there are some people for whom that
still works well so i've also seen
people who lose 100 pounds
and
70 of it is
fat and 30 of it is lean and their net
better off because they were starting at
a body weight of 300 pounds
and they certainly had the amount of
lean mass to improve so their body fat
maybe goes from 50 percent to
35 i'm kind of making those numbers up
so they're moving in the right direction
the point here is
i think you need to ask yourself before
you
go on an aggressive trf regimen how much
muscle mass can you afford to lose and
if the answer is none which is it should
be the answer for most people by the way
most of us don't have the freedom to
lose any lean mass
then you've got to make sure you're not
restricting protein
and that you're
thinking about when you can refuel in
relation to exercise so peter when
people
listening are kind of trying to figure
out okay
how much muscle do they have can they
get a baseline
and then if they are doing various diets
or time restricted feeding things of
that nature and they want to see
what actually went up and down what's
the best way for them to do it is it a
dexa scan is there another way outside
of that where they can test this
i think dex is the only way to do it
truthfully i mean obviously it's not the
single most accurate way to do it there
are more accurate ways to do them but
those would all be done in a research
setting
dexa is relatively inexpensive a hundred
dollars in most places maybe if you're
in a place like new york it's more but
we're talking of something in the low
hundreds of dollars not something that
is thousands of dollars and
the information it yields is also
segmental which is really valuable so
unlike the sort of buoyancy-based tests
which i think are quite inaccurate
anyway you don't get the segmental
information you don't get the
information of visceral adipose tissue
so
when we do a dexa scan
we're looking at lots of information
we're looking at bmd bone mineral
density total body fat things like that
but what i'm really interested in is
what's your fat free mass index so
that's the total lean tissue
in kilograms divided by height in meters
squared
the almi which is the appendicular lean
mass index which is the same as the ffmi
except it's only using the lean mass of
the four limbs not including the torso
we're looking at vat and we're putting
all of these things on a nomogram to see
where you rank for your age and sex and
that's where i think people need to be
really focused and frankly i care much
more about those metrics than i care
about your total body fat percent if
your body fat percent is at the
40th percentile but your almi ffmi
are at the 90th percentile and your vat
is at the 10th percentile
that's perfectly adequate and again a
lot of that
total body fat in some ways comes down
to a little bit of
vanity once the biomarkers are
themselves also great yeah i think that
was one of the most interesting things
we had an internal meeting about this
other day which is just
it surprised me how cheap a dexa scan is
and if people just search the city
they're in in dexa i think they'd be
surprised to find that out and then same
thing with vo2 and i know we'll talk
about an exercise here but some of the
places that do dexa scans can also do
vo2 max tests and so
it's something that if people haven't
done it it's worth looking into it
making that investment in because of
what you can learn from there before we
move on is there anything else in
nutrition
do you want to touch on i think on the
topic of protein we're probably
under doing it for most people i don't
think i was paying enough attention to
it and i think the rdas the recommended
daily allowances are kind of out to
lunch you know the rda for protein is
something to the tune of
i want to say it's like .8
grams per kilogram of body weight or
something pathetic like that
you take an 80 kilogram person so some
of the ways like about a buck 75
and that person should only be eating 65
grams of protein a day or something
asinine like point eight to one
and the reality is i think the rda
is predicated on how much protein you
need to like live
versus how much protein you need to
thrive
and so
i think when you look at those data you
realize it's probably closer to two
grams per kilogram or about a gram per
pound of body weight
and that quote unquote toxicity of too
much protein toxicity is that well it's
generally kidney toxicity if you consume
enough protein you're going to over tax
the kidneys because that's how we
excrete the excess nitrogen and you're
looking at somewhere in the order of
three to four
grams per kilogram before you get into
the places where you're going to start
to challenge your kidneys abilities to
take care of excess nitrogen so
this is something that we're also
becoming much more attuned to in our
patients
it seems to be a really big problem in
middle aged women that's where we're
probably seeing the biggest
deficits or
these women that show up with no muscle
mass eating
no protein
doing very little strength training i
mean to me that is a recipe for
a shorter life but more importantly a
lower quality of life
i think it makes sense then to kind of
go a little bit on the path we're going
which is exercise
so
i don't want to say there's a lot of
things that change with your view on
exercise because you've always been
a big proponent of it but from how i've
even heard you talk about it it seems
you're
more sold than you've ever been on
the importance of exercise
in someone's longevity so do you want to
maybe talk about
just the theme of exercise and where
you've evolved what your thinking is now
and why you even put more of an emphasis
than before
yeah you're right it seems
odd that i would even be talking about
this given that exercise has always been
such an important part of my life
personally but i think
i've now come to
appreciate the magnitude of
the
value
that is brought to a person's lifespan
and health span
by having higher cardio respiratory
fitness and more strength
and you can't really get more strength
without training so more strength is
synonymous with training with strength
training obviously i think i posted
something on this a long time ago or not
that long ago maybe a month or so ago on
instagram and twitter where i kind of
walk through some of the data on this
we'll link to that but the gist of it is
when you look at the
improvements in all cause mortality
by moving up the
chain of cardiorespiratory fitness so
moving from being in the bottom 25th
percentile
to the
25th to 50th percentile
they have terminology for all of those
things like low below average above
average
high and elite which would be sort of
bottom 25th percentile 25th to 50th 50th
to 75th 75th to like 97 and a half and
then the top call it two two and a half
percent
as you march up those
strata
your all-cause mortality drops and it
drops
at
levels that
aren't appreciated by any other
intervention
quitting smoking going from having
end-stage renal disease to not and it's
easier to look at these in reverse so
comparing someone with end-stage renal
disease to someone who doesn't have it a
smoker to a non-smoker someone with type
2 diabetes someone who does not those
are big multipliers of risk but they're
dwarfed by
the multiplier and risk that you would
go from having a very high vo2 max to a
low vo2 max now of course these
associations have lots of
interplay with other variables there's
some genetic component to this to be
sure
and there's obviously a healthy user
bias so i'm not acting like those things
aren't present but the point here is
if you can get yourself to exercise
versus not that's a big driver of
mortality reduction
and the vo2 max becomes one way that we
can track the progress you're making on
that metric similarly with strength
similarly with muscle mass and things
like that turns out by the way that
strength matters more than muscle mass
but muscle mass is a very good proxy for
strength you know it's funny i'm two
days now post-op from this shoulder
surgery and it's really interesting
how much i've noticed my grip is weaker
in my right hand which is the side i was
operated on
than pre-op so
not being able to recruit the full
musculature of my shoulder and scapula
on the right
means i actually have slightly weaker
grip in my right hand and that's why i
think grip strength
is a great proxy for
longevity it's always been known to be
that way and the question is why and i
think there's lots of reasons among them
it's just a great proxy for overall body
strength and muscle mass but i think
it's also a very functional form of
strength
basically everything in your upper body
is mediated through your hands and if
your grip is weak everything downstream
of that is weak when you watch someone
who's got a weak grip deadlifting it's
very difficult for them to deadlift
correctly because they don't create a
proper wedge they don't create enough
tension between the bar
and their torso because their grip is
weak and if they don't create that
tension they're going to compromise
their lift and by the way then they're
more likely to get injured how are you
training specifically for grip strength
i mean a lot of carrying things so
i'll do a lot of super sets i'm doing a
farmer's carry in between other workouts
one of my favorite i won't be doing
these things for quite a while of course
as i'm recovering but i love doing like
the ski erg so i'll do a one minute
all-out ski erg followed by a one-minute
farmer's carry with i don't know 70
pounds in each hand so whatever that is
probably 75 percent of my body weight or
80 of my body weight and just go back
and forth and back and forth between
those types of things but basically
picking up heavy things is how you train
for it you know how much i love dead
hanging so that's another great way to
train grip strength what's your record
for dead hang these days
well the last long one i did was four
minutes 35 seconds
which is insane and was that pre or post
workout
that was a clean day so i was doing
some katsu training some bfr training
but not particularly intensive on my
grip so that was a fresh start the other
thing that
i've come to the conclusion of in just
talking to you and listening to podcasts
and meetings and things of that nature
is a lot of times the feedback we can
get is
when you talk about some of this stuff
it's not widely available to all when
you look at some of the drugs it's
either it can be cost prohibitive
or really tough to access them or find
doctors who will prescribe them but the
thing with exercise is
it's available to everyone it just
requires a lot of hard work but from
what i've heard you saying correct me if
i'm wrong you still think it's one of
the most potent things that people can
do
outside of what drugs or supplements
they take outside of other things they
can do is just
exercise and working on building that
muscle strength and muscle size
to this day just
can make such a difference in someone's
not only health span but also ultimately
their lifespan yeah i mean that's the
good news and that's the bad news the
good news is
this tool called exercise which is broad
includes a lot of things it's not just
one thing so by definition it needs to
be multimodal it has an unbelievable
impact on your lifespan and health span
probably bigger than anything else
and it's available to everyone it has
the least barrier to entry the drawback
is it's the hardest
i think it takes the most time that's
for sure and it's the most uncomfortable
welcome to the i will teach you to be
rich podcast
my name is ramit sethi and i'm the new
york times best-selling author of i will
teach you be rich
for the last 20 years i've been studying
money psychology
when i ask people what words come to
mind when they think of money here's
what they say
guilt
stress
and not enough
when i ask them what's your rich life
they almost all say i want to do what i
want when i want
then i say okay that sounds pretty good
so what do you want
and that's when they stare at me blankly
most people have never actually thought
about what they want to use their money
for
that's because everybody teaches us how
to save
but nobody teaches us how to spend
i learned that when most people look at
their personal finances they see random
numbers in a spreadsheet
when i look at someone's finances i see
a two-week trip to italy i see being
able to pick up your children from
school every afternoon
or i see you being able to retire early
i wanted to show how you can use money
to create your rich life this podcast
takes you into real conversations with
real people about real numbers
the kind of conversations you have never
heard before
welcome to the i will teach you to be
rich podcast
you're
netting 80 000 a month and you're
questioning my audible 12 subscription
every day there's a problem here we
filed our taxes jointly and
i had to sign for taxes recently
couldn't believe my eyes i didn't even
know how much we made i had to sign a
hundred seventy five thousand dollars
per month
my yard is in shambles there's no reason
for this when we fly we fly as basic
economy as we can when we stay in hotels
it's the cheapest i am cheap i am frugal
i am cheap there's no mistake about that
there are folks that have much more
money than i do that end up going
bankrupt like what happened to them they
didn't pay attention and they started
spending extravagantly and they got
themselves in trouble she could or has
spent money in ways that i thought
should not have spent in the middle
school and the real clincher here is
that because he earns the money and
physically has more access to the money
he directs it he manages it i do believe
that he wants to change i do believe
that he realizes the damage that has
been done
i'm not
optimistic that he can actually do it i
recently got a message
and i have to read it to you here's what
it said
we have a 10 million dollar net worth
and a 2.5 million dollar income
and we still share a netflix password
please help
my wife of 21 years is threatening
divorce
today i'd like you to meet michelle and
charles
charles what was going on when you wrote
that message to me
we're having a very toxic discussion
about money i know you say you can't
help cheap people but i am cheap i am
frugal i am cheap and there are certain
things that that i feel i don't want to
spend money on right like i i bought a
fancy car a couple years ago paid all
cash a fancy car i'll invest in that
like the car
it was more like luxury right i mean is
it a tesla luxury because i didn't look
at that as luxury i mean he's a tech
executive who bought a used tesla with
the lowest battery power that's not a
luxury to me
i'm going to try to find out when this
started affecting their relationship
so the night before our marriage so
we're planning the wedding and
everyone's responsible for whatever
thing
and
he comes to me the night before the
wedding and says did you bring your
checkbook i'm like no and all the frenzy
how can i forget how can i bring my
checkbook i was like why he's like
because you have to pay the the
musicians i'm like what difference does
it make we're getting married tomorrow
and
that stuck with me i am i almost called
the wedding off because i just felt like
who we're getting married we're going
from
separate to joint why would he ask for
my checkbook and so if that's been the
theme
for 21 years sometimes i refer back to
that like the checkbook moment and
that's been a problem so this started
very early his idea of spending
is spinning to make more money and then
make more money i'm constantly saying
like why do you need more money oh
because i want to invest more money well
why do you need that why do you need
that at some point you die and you're
just doing this to give it away to other
people the problem is that we're married
and
what his beliefs are he doesn't realize
that they affect me immensely i mean
literally to the point where it's broken
my spirit
the reason why we're coming to you now
is because after all these years
it's just too much i mean i i remember
another podcast you did and you asked
them to rate it from zero to ten we're
at a nine we've been in a nine and a
half for for many years maybe the last
10 years and i just can't take it
anymore
i think that one of the biggest question
marks in my mind is when i talk to
michelle about what does our risk life
look like and i start seeing dollar
signs i start seeing hearing i want to
fly first class i want to buy a huge
house i want to stay in in the western
united states in a high cost geography
and i'm saying okay my initial plans
were x her plans are 1.5 x so unless we
get an agreement alignment on what that
rich life looks like
it's going to be hard for me to to
pencil it out why don't we just do it
right now well let's just do it right
now keep it very high level here's the
thing before we do it that's exactly why
i haven't done it because
it's not
it doesn't stop there it's not here are
my five things that i'd like to do
it's set in stone so if i give you five
things right now that i'd like to do
that's my rich life that's it there
shouldn't be there can't be a single
dollar spent anywhere else
the minute i spit out the first one he
has a problem with it because it's like
oh my god that's spending money on
something that i would not otherwise
spend money on i'm a very plantable guy
i like to stick to a plan and so but i'm
trying to convince michelle that hey
i've learned to be more flexible
and we're not gonna it's not gonna be
set in stone but let's be thoughtful
about putting a plan together don't just
kind of spit out numbers or ideas let's
be thoughtful and make sure that
something you put forward is something
that you put some thought into okay are
you seeing
michelle's reaction right now
she's shaking her head what is the
implication of
you needing to remind your wife of 21
years
that you both need to be thoughtful i
guess the implication is that uh
she's she's not
she has not been thoughtful if you were
to say hey babe you make the plan for
the vacation here's the checkbook
what is the implication that what would
she do with that checkbook
that she's gonna spend a bunch of money
thoughtlessly like a huge amount like an
amount of money that's going to set you
back in the poor house
do you think she would do that
i don't think she would do that
intentionally
but i think that
that
she could or has spent money in ways
that i thought that should not should
not have spent in those ways do you
think
there is a vacation that the two of you
could go on
do you think there's an amount she could
spend that would materially affect your
finances negatively
no
say it again say it in a full sentence
so you hear that yourself
i don't think it's possible for michelle
to spend money on one vacation
that would materially impact our
finances
however agree
just stop right there just stop right
there i'm gonna save you from yourself
okay trust me this is it i'm saving you
yeah
i'm saving all of us right now
okay okay i had to stop him from some
long monologue that he was about to go
on and two things just happened right
there one you could see and one you
could not first charles acknowledged
that there is literally no amount
michelle could spend on a vacation that
would materially affect their finances
to put it another way she could plan a
500 000 trip and they would make that
much money back in a few months
in interest alone
but you'll notice how i had to almost
drag this out of him
even when he admitted it he felt he had
to caveat it to cover his bases to
explain
i wish you could have seen michelle's
face
she looked
so sad
she looked frustrated
the problem with needing to dot every
eye and cross every t
and i'm talking to all you logical dorks
out there who feel the need to explain
and show the math and roi of every life
decision
the problem is that nobody likes being
told all the things you might do wrong
especially when you've been someone's
partner for 21 years
michelle is looking for a little
partnership here a little trust
to focus on what can go right instead of
only focusing on what can go wrong
[Music]
the house is my biggest thing
the house
uh maintaining it
beautifying it making it making it
comfortable
making it comfortable for what for my
family and friends but the problem is
it's not and then another thing that i i
kind of picked up as as charles was
talking
is
it's what he
finds valuable it's what he
finds pleasure in so when we talk about
the tesla
that's that benefited him solely when we
talk about the garage remodel that
benefits him solely so the disconnect
comes when
it benefits him it doesn't benefit him
in any kind of way
that's when the friction happens so he
could care less about furniture in the
living room could care less that's our
friction and it's everything to me he
could care less about landscaping could
care less but it's everything to me
and the the real clincher here is that
because he earns the money and
physically has more access to the money
he he directs it he manages it so buying
is just a wish his his desires are
actually played out because he
physically earns it and doesn't view
this as our money
i would love him to take enough money
that he needs he said he needs 150 000
take it give me the rest i mean
literally like you only need 150
you're
netting 80 000 a month and you're
questioning my audible 12 subscription
every day
there's a problem here i you know where
we filed our taxes jointly couldn't
believe my eyes
i didn't even know how much we made i
had to sign 175 000
per month
my yard is in shambles there's no reason
for this when we fly we fly as basic
economy as we can when we say in hotels
it's the cheapest it comes down to the
worst that he said before convincing
being thoughtful being planful
i'm all those things
i plan i research i i weigh the and
measure i i don't just willy-nilly just
say hey i want to buy a couch today but
those words are unacceptable and they
shut me down
it's often the things that make us
successful in the first place
that turn around and cost us everything
charles has been very financially
successful
and yet he's taken it too far
he's become cheap
he's become disconnected from what
really matters
his wife is frustrated maybe beyond
saving
now the good news is that they both came
to me open-mindedly
willing to listen and potentially change
and as i started having this
conversation with him i saw how much
there is to unpack with charles and
michelle
the first
and the big elephant in the room is that
cheapness is one of the most difficult
afflictions to change you know why
because deep down
cheap people don't really think it's a
problem
they'll often shroud their behavior in
all kinds of positive phrases well you
know i'm a conscious spender there's
certain things i care about certain
things i don't i would never spend on
that
but when you zoom out and you ask them
what is your
philosophy on money costing you
well suddenly
they have to start to acknowledge that
friends aren't inviting them out as much
that they're accumulating a huge amount
in their checking account and they have
no idea what to do with it in this case
charles has to acknowledge that his wife
is extremely unhappy
it becomes clear that this is a much
much more complex psychological issue
than the amount of money
in a savings account
is michelle a good mom she's a great mom
she a good wife excellent wife
good partner
very good partner
how come
in your statements the two-parter
you
give her the warning
of what she might do wrong
where's that coming from
i think it's coming from because we
approach
things differently
now the good news is that charles and
michelle came to me with an open mind
and charles admits he wants to change he
knows that it's costing him a lot
but old habits die hard
he is really struggling to come around
on the idea of spending money okay he
has certain beliefs they're very
rational and analytical and they are
causing him to look at money through
only one lens progress but after 21
years
of these types of conversations michelle
does not believe
that charles is actually going to change
and every time we get close to him
saying he's going to change
she doesn't believe it we have a lot of
scar tissue here
and this is not going to be easy
what i hear beneath the surface is this
fear that if you take michelle's
approach which you've described as being
more intuitive more spontaneous
that somehow you will lose the core of
what made you successful
and that suddenly you're going to just
lose it all and oh my god i dropped 75
000 on dinner tonight
can you see a reality where you ever
spend 75 000 on one dinner charles
no
no i don't think so it's it would be
very hard to do that can you ever see a
reality where michelle spends that much
on a single dinner
uh for for the two of us now okay so
knowing that you have so solidly
anchored your analytical self in
what i would say is this fear of if i
let go just a little bit i'm going to
turn into a pile of mush that just
spends money everywhere it's never going
to happen never in fact i could work
with you every single day for the next
20 years
it would still be very challenging for
you to just go out there and conceive of
money the same way michelle does
it is really really hard for people to
turn the page in their rich life
let me explain what i mean for highly
successful people like charles
all of their skills of saving and
investing and planning and optimizing
got them to the top of the mountain
so from the outside you look at them and
you say you made it why are you
agonizing over 200 jeans
but to them
they see the very skills that got them
here
as identical
with themselves i'm gonna do a little
guided conversation here i can tell that
if i let these two just talk to each
other it's gonna quickly devolve into
you didn't let me do that and well i
think this
there's so much resentment built up here
that i'm gonna have to micromanage this
conversation a little maybe offer a
little bit of training
watch what i do
i'm gonna ask a few questions
listen to the questions and listen to
her answers okay
what is your absolute dream destination
budget is irrelevant probably italy
why italy what would you do there i just
think it's an it seems like an exotic
you know
beautiful country
i i would enjoy the food and the scenery
and the people fantastic and what kind
of foods are you thinking about having
when you go there
yummy pasta
what kind well if i'm not on my diet
fettuccine and penny and pizza
love it what kind of weather are you
imagining is it summertime are you
wearing a long coat what are you
thinking it's it's more summery and more
sun's out
beautiful where are you staying when
you're in italy
a beautiful home a beautiful
resort type field very nice and who do
you have with you on this trip
ideally my husband
but but if he if i'm gonna
if the price of that is him
belittling me for even wanting what i
just described then a girlfriend or
something no no no no this is charles
who's fully bought in
fully he's actually saying to you
babe
i made a special reservation tonight
don't worry
put on something nice let's go out to
this place how would that feel
i would feel great but you know
21 years of not having that is tough to
get over i love it and final question
for you when you
get to the italian airport and you get
on your plane which seat are you sitting
in
i'm definitely in first class my
vacation starts the minute i leave my
door
very good okay
charles what did you hear in my
questions
your questions were geared around how
this would make her feel at her
experiences and it really
put her in the driver's seat her in
complete control
of planning and experiencing this
vacation very nice wow very good pickups
on all those things
now did you notice at one point
she kind of went a little negative
and did you notice what i did there
yeah you tried to stay away from that
try to say let's set that aside for now
yeah i think that that's the that's the
scar tissue coming back and you know she
can't imagine me
doing that after 21 years and so that's
what we need to overcome i agree do you
think you could possibly do that after
21 years sure
okay
i don't know if that's true i hope it is
that will be for the two of you to
decide right we have one conversation
together the two of you have a lifelong
relationship right and i want to totally
acknowledge that is a lot of scar tissue
21 years but
i do think it's possible to change i've
seen it it starts with little steps it
starts with just a series of questions
like this
what did you not hear
in our conversation i was waiting for
you to ask the money question
there is no money question
guess what
you won
you could do that entire trip guess how
long it would take you to earn enough to
pay for that entire trip
i don't know how long you tell me yes i
mean you're an investor give me a better
uh
so maybe that trip was going to cost
maybe
20 grand
okay
um
took about a month one day
not really but about a month one day one
month one day one day maybe two
maybe two
you have
approximately 11 million dollars
interest is earning you make a
considerable income
one day
two days hey let's even be conservative
five days five days
five days
and what happens
if you were to spend that money
i think michelle will uh
be really really happy
all right so i want you to take the same
approach i took try it it's going to be
uncomfortable but i'm here with you
okay landscaping so so michelle
landscaping
what's your vision
for
our front
yard and our backyard like what do you
what do you see as the complete vision
what would make you
absolutely happy
with if if we got the front yard and
backyard landscaped
well if ramit asks that same question
that i can answer it
because coming from you i'm like uh
michelle i know you're tense i get it
and i know that there's a lifetime of
beliefs right now that are just right at
your throat and they're bubbling up i
totally get that
charles is
playing ball here right and he's doing
some uncomfortable stuff
and so what i want to ask from you is
that you play ball as well and if it
means
really trying to acknowledge those
feelings inside but set them aside for
just three minutes that's what i would
ask i understand it's a bit contrived i
understand that me asking you to do this
does not
remove those feelings they are there
they are real
but in order for us to move forward
together sometimes the best way to do it
is to act as if
so let's start with the behavior and
let's see if often our feelings can
follow
so
my vision is just when you walk up the
steps toward our home you just want to
be home it's inviting
it's plush
it's modern it it's well cared for
maintained it just would make me so
make me feel so good if i just drive
home and walk up to a home i want to
walk into
um the backyard same thing i just want
to be able to walk outside of my house
feel really good about being outside i
would love to
eat dinner outside sit outside just go
outside to just think and just i just
want to see something pleasing i just um
all i could see is just a new deck and
and
comfortable chairs and greenery
um just those are the things that i'd
love to look at
what are some things you'd love to do
out there once we get it all fixed up i
just want to spend time out there i just
want to sit down on a chair and look out
to the yard look at the lemon tree look
at the apricot tree look at plush grass
i just
i just wanted a feeling of calming
calmness i don't need a party or
anything i just want it for our family
for now just a place where i can go and
retreat and then
when you think about the front yard what
are the things that you think will
really kind of make the the front yard
pop i just want it well maintained you
know it
it hurts to see everyone around me
changing their landscape fixing up their
yard replanting if the plants have died
rearranging things i just feel after 11
years and nothing has been done you know
the rocks have slid down the slope i
just want those things filled in because
the way it looks now
i don't want that to be a reflection of
who i am today
do you want this to happen right now do
you want us to to happen later on like
what do you want when you want to make
this happen
well i think it's long overdue so the
win would be right now and and what can
i do to help you make this become a
reality
loosen up the money
like not not control it to the in the
sense that you decide how much is enough
and just trust me that
that i'm not here to spend multi
thousand dollars on the project i'm just
here to get a nice update to the to the
property
would it be okay
if i provided just a teensy-weensy bit
of feedback or input into the
landscaping
this will be overall vision but i'd like
to have the opportunity
to have a little bit of input
on the landscape would that be okay with
you on your terms of course
anything other than money and how much
something cost
if you want to suggest bushes or tree
arrangements great but nothing about how
much nothing around money okay
so i am committed to being a partner in
this
and not talking about money not talking
about how much
and i'm committed to giving you whatever
vision you want for the front yard and
backyard landscaping uh and to make it
become a reality i'm i'm like grinning
from ear to ear because i'm like could
this be real
like can we call you back if that
doesn't work can we get this in writing
michelle you're almost in disbelief over
here yeah
yeah do you think that it's gonna happen
i don't know because
i believe i do believe that he wants to
change i do believe that he realizes the
damage that has been done
i'm not
optimistic that he can actually do it i
i haven't seen change in this area of
money
i get it yeah
i get it you're you're cautious about
hope i get that exactly
you have two choices here
option one is
honey i trust you
it's your call
you don't even look at it you hand it
right back to her
option two what's that option charles
you know that one very well
[Music]
this is
how much is this going to cost it seems
very expensive
[Music]
and that phrase
what do you think that phrase saying
that to michelle will cost you
to help make sure that charles actually
changes i help them set up something i
call a worry-free number
imagine when you go to the grocery store
if you're in the checkout lane and you
see a pack of gum do you sit there and
deliberate over whether you can afford
it do you agonize how that pack of gum
is gonna affect your early retirement
number
no
a pack of gum is so small you don't even
worry about it
a worry-free number is a number below
which you don't worry about it you don't
even think about it
now in your early 20s your worry-free
number might be five dollars that might
be a pack of gum or a coffee
but for multi-millionaires like charles
and michelle
their worry-free number should be much
higher
so below three thousand dollars
for the next
six months
you're not going to talk about it
i've been
begging for a peloton for the last year
since coving done done it's ordered
tonight wow it really gives me great joy
to spend other people's money i think i
just ordered michelle a peloton with
michelle and charles's money what a
great job i have
now you have freedom to dream yeah
peloton
love it amazing order it tonight and you
get on that peloton you're gonna feel so
good it's gonna feel like charles feels
getting into his tesla
that's a beautiful thing charles what is
what are you going to spend this
worry-free money on potentially
i nothing i'd like to go to a um
fantasy baseball camp
the dodgers
in vero beach
and spend a week with the hall of famers
that's less than 3 000 bucks
no but
no but i also like to get uh some
autographed mohammad ali uh gloves
signed
and uh get a jackie robinson sign check
get some sportsmen
where did all this stuff come from all
of a sudden you have this list of things
you're going to get i love it where did
this come from well i read your book and
i started to kind of to sketch out my
rich life and this is on it okay very
good so sounds like two of those things
fall under worry free and the third one
probably needs to be some kind of
discussion right this dodgers thing
great love it both of you starting to
realize
okay we spent this money it did not
change a single thing for us financially
in fact it was just sitting here in this
swamp just sitting here in a savings
account or a checking account just
sitting there doing nothing and now
every day i wake up i go to the exercise
room i have a peloton i feel joy
love it you two did it
you got married you raised a beautiful
family
you became
wildly financially successful and you're
still really young
mobile everything's put together you're
great
it would be a tragedy
to wait another 10 years which would
turn into another 10. yeah
the bitterness would deepen
possibly divorce um
we wouldn't get to enjoy all the hard
work we went through to to be in this
financial position to be it would be a
wasted opportunity what i would like you
to work towards
north star is not just for you both to
be spending more money i don't really
care how much you spend i want you to
have a rich life
and rich life means michelle you are
happy in your beautiful home i want that
for you you are traveling
charles a rich life for you
is feeling like your money is not out of
control
that you will have enough and to know it
like deep down in your spreadsheet bones
and
to be just a little more adventurous
than you are today
i'm ramit sethi and you've been
listening to a clip of an episode from
the i will teach you to be rich podcast
which features real stories from real
couples including real numbers
do you think charles can actually change
even at the end of this episode michelle
wasn't sure
but we received a follow-up from charles
six months later and i think you'll be
very surprised by what you hear
you can go to iwt.com
follow-ups to hear the full episode and
you'll be able to read the full letter
from charles
updating us on what happened
thanks for listening to i will teach you
to be rich
[Music]
and now a clip from the tim ferris show
one book that came up in my research and
feel free to confirm or deny because you
can't believe everything you read on the
internet but are you a fan of
meditations by marcus aurelius
yes
why is that what is the meaning of this
book for you or what role does it play
for you marcus aurelius was of course
the great philosopher king plato had
always said that the ideal society would
be a society where the king was also a
philosopher we have that right now in
america
i was excited to see where that was
going
i i kid i kid because i love anyway
marcus aurelius was that he was a great
scholar and he was a great leader
and he
was like all philosophers somebody who
spent his life in examination of the
human condition and and of his own
existence and his meditations are what
survives of his journals
and
they're so beautiful and they're so
immediate i mean the other thing that
great art is is that it's eternal right
so the way that marcus aurelius speaks
to himself in his journal feels like it
could have been written yesterday
he is struggling through the same
eternal questions that all of us are
struggling through
what is the meaning of my life how do i
serve without
being destroyed in service
how do i handle
failure
how do i handle difficult people
how do i handle the limits of my
powerlessness you know what happens when
there are situations that are beyond my
control
and and he was a stoic as well so a lot
of it is just about
can i survive my emotions and stoicism
in that philosophical realm doesn't mean
white-knuckling your way through pain
and pretending not to feel it it means
achieving going back to whitman
achieving that sense of being both in
and out of the game at the same time
being involved and like up to your neck
in the messiness of life while at the
same time achieving a tiny bit of
detachment to watch the
i guess what the in eastern philosophy
they would call the karmic dilemma that
you're in and recognizing that there may
be limitations to how much you can
control that and i love the way that he
speaks to himself
directly in his journals the way that
he'll say to himself come on come on man
like come on marcus you know like dude
get it together like it's time like this
is a moment for you to act you can go
down now or you can find your strength
you can find your resilience like the
way that he coaches himself
i find that incredibly inspiring and and
i also think
my friend martha beck who i talk about a
lot because she's a great teacher but
she has a great a great teaching that
she gives people when they're full of
anxiety and full of fear there's ways
that you can learn to speak to yourself
that will actually mitigate that and one
of the ways that she teaches is that she
coaches her clients to
write down let their fear speak so you
just give your fear it's it's day right
you have to respect it it exists it's
part of you you don't want to
cast it away or attack it you just open
up your journal and you invite your fear
to write down everything that it's
afraid of and you listen politely and
with non-violent compassion to your fear
as it speaks
and then once it's done and it's had its
say you say thank you so much for
sharing that i'm really i'm really
grateful to that you trust me enough to
be this vulnerable and to tell me
everything that you're afraid of and
then you say to your fear i'm now going
to ask you now that you've had a chance
to speak if you'll step aside and i'm
going to bring another aspect of myself
forward and i'm going to ask it to speak
so if fear if you just step aside for a
moment i'm now inviting wisdom
into the room and now i'm going to ask
wisdom to write down what it thinks and
what it suggests in this case
and it's extraordinary to see the wisdom
that people find in themselves that
you're not just made of fear you're also
made of grace and of wisdom and those
meditations of marcus aurelius it feels
like that's what he's doing you know
he's writing to himself from a place of
fear anxiety and uncertainty
and then he's writing back to himself
from a place of wisdom
and saying this is what you're upset
about i recognize that i see that and
now i'm going to ask wisdom to come into
the room and this is what it would
suggest
so it's so beautiful and intimate you
know to get to see a great mind like
that working with itself in such
intimate setting
well hot damn am i glad i asked about
marcus aurelius
and for people who have no familiarity
with marcus aurelius to put the
philosopher label also in perspective
from the
leadership or within the sort of mesh of
leadership he was the last of the rulers
known as the five good emperors and also
the last emperor of the pax romana
which was an age of peace and stability
in the roman empire so very
highly effective
highly revered and also highly
reflective
and so i definitely second the
recommendation i would love to chat
thank you so much tim for for for
putting him into of course because i'm
so fascinated by
spirituality and philosophy i forgot to
mention that he was also a badass roman
emperor
he also had a job he also had a really
good a really really good job and he was
excellent at it so yes thank you for
pointing that out
of course and he wasn't just a really
thoughtful guy he was also running like
the world's greatest empire
yeah yeah he was i mean fascinating
character and in some ways a reluctant
leader also much like cincinnatus and
some others who george washington comes
to mind
fascinating fascinating guy and i would
love to
leapfrog to
martha beck because you mentioned this
parts work
it would which would be one way to put
it letting the fear speak
which makes me think also something
called internal family systems or ifs
which exactly what it is yep
super super
i'll use the word interesting and also
incredibly effective i've seen i've seen
ifs
mostly as used by
michael and annie mitthoeffer who are
therapists who work very closely with
a non-profit called maps in developing
protocols for mdma assisted
psychotherapy for ptsd and
both
ifs
and well i don't want to actually say
this about ifs but cognitive behavioral
therapy has a lot of its roots in
stoic philosophy which has been used for
trauma and ptsd
and then ifs does as well that's just as
a bit of context for folks and
i'd love for you to speak to what else
you've learned from
martha beck what are some of the other
things that have really stuck for you
i'll give you one she's when i met her i
met her years ago at an oprah winfrey
event she if you don't know of her she's
a life coach she's a writer she's
actually the person for whom the term
life coach was invented
she was the original life coach and and
i always say she was oprah winfrey's
life coach everybody so if you just want
to if you just want to know like some
credentials uh that's martha and when i
met her i met her around the time raya
was sick i had i had reached out to her
weirdly not there are no coincidences
but we had met years ago and then she
wrote a book called diana herself that
landed on my desk and i read it and i
was like this is so dazzling and and i
need to reach out to her personally and
tell her how great it is so that
reestablished our contact with each
other and then very shortly after that
contract was established ray got sick
and martha was right there for us and
really walking us through that and that
death and dying experience in such a a
remarkable way i i can truly say that i
it would have been a very much more
painful experience without her help one
of the things that i said to raya about
martha once i first started having
conversations with her was i said i've
always felt like i'd play the game of
life pretty well
martha
took the ball and just left the arena
like
here i am struggling to play the game
well she's just like now i'm not even
gonna play the game by its rules
and i didn't even know that you could
just leave the game and and she's so
wild off the charts and her wildness is
that she has this very strong belief
that
your intuitive nature will take care of
everything
but in order to listen to it
you have to step away from trauma and
you have to step away from culture
and that often means you have to unlearn
every single thing you were ever taught
by your family and by your culture about
what
is right and wrong
and you have to become a completely
natural wild intuitive being
and you have to guide yourself purely
based on
essentially what she would say is based
on what your body tells you
so
any time that you and that's located
like i'm putting my hand on it right now
but it's that center located between
like your navel and your sternum
that's often extremely emotionally
reactive so
if i don't want to do something
if i don't like somebody
that thing knows it's a compass that's
never wrong
and
culture and trauma and family and
training have taught me to override it
constantly right so
somebody
invites me to an event
and i
my
sternum
naval area starts to feel sick
because i don't want to do it but my
training and my culture tells me that i
have to
that's me overriding the only
navigational system that is truly my own
in order to be a good member of society
or it's my fear that's overriding it
because i say oh i have to say yes to
that invitation because i have to
network you know and if i say no to this
really powerful person then you know so
and that overrides it
anytime you say yes with your mind when
your body says no you will lead yourself
farther and farther and farther away
from your path and so the work that
martha does is about teaching people how
to trust that and only that and she has
navigated her life based on that and
only that and she started navigating it
that way not for fun but because she was
dying she was literally dying of several
autoimmune diseases
and she was dying of being a good person
she was dying of doing everything
exactly right as she had been taught by
her mormon upbringing and then by
harvard she went and got three degrees
at harvard so she went from one really
oppressive culture which was mormonism
into another one which was academia and
the entire time was trying to be the
best good moral ethical person as per
culture's recommendations and she was
literally dying of it and the way that
she cured herself was that she went on
what she called an integrity cleanse and
this is the most badass thing i have
ever heard anybody do
this that is amazing this is what yeah
it all sounds good until you find out
what you have to do
true for so many things dude it's so
hardcore like she like she got a watch
she got a digital watch this was years
ago before phones you can do it now on
your phone but like
ask yourself if you really want to but
she she did it because her alternative
was literally to die and that's often
what will make people have to change
she got this watch
she put a timer on it to have it go off
every 30 minutes
and every 30 minutes whatever she was
doing she would check and see if she was
lying
and
if she was lying she'd correct it
so every 30 minutes
every 30 minutes so that means
you're on the phone with your sister
and your sister saying you guys coming
for christmas this year and you say yeah
i can't wait we're still looking forward
to it
actually no i don't want to come
i don't want to come we're not coming
next 30 minutes another one beep beep
beep everything every single interaction
every single conversation no more polite
social lies nothing this extreme
integrity cleanse and she said it was
the most amazing thing in the world she
lost every single member of her family
she lost her marriage she lost like she
lost
the work path that she was on and what
she became was herself and what she got
back was her health and her well-being
and her intuition and her instincts and
then she had a few people left at the
end of that and they were her core
people and from that she built her
entire new life that she's still living
in now
so it's a massively badass thing to do
but
it's pretty cool and she she said you
know i've softened it a bit she's like
i'll tell a social line now just to be
nice but it's
it you know she's got a new book coming
out next year that's that's all about
this that i can't wait to be out into
the world because it's so
the amount of integrity that she lives
with and the amount of integrity that
she taught me to live with are huge and
when you asked me you know was it hard
for me to
tell my husband that i was in love with
rhea
that was directly a result of seeing the
way that martha lives and just having to
be in integrity at the same time as
being in respect to somebody i'll i'll
give you one more martha back line that
i love
she says there are certain moments of
your life where you where you're
standing in front of a bonfire
and you have to jump
you just have to jump into it and you
have to be willing to
burn away everything that you've been
taught and
everything that you're afraid of and
just do it and she said and i remember
her telling me this was such glee she
goes it's such a cool moment
that you're in and and she said this to
me you know as i was leaving my marriage
and going to be with reyes she said that
that these bonfire moments are so
fantastic because
there's only two things that can happen
when you jump into a bonfire
one of them is that you find out that it
wasn't actually a bonfire that you were
afraid that it was going to burn you to
pieces and and it actually didn't it
wasn't as scary as you thought you did
it you took the leap it turned out to be
kind of like warm and soft and easy so
it was no big deal
the other thing that can happen
is that it is a bonfire
and you are incinerated and your entire
life is incinerated by it
and that's even better because then you
get to be reborn as a phoenix on the
other side completely new so either way
you win so there's no reason not to
you'll either jump in and find out it
was nothing or you'll jump in and you'll
be destroyed and that's awesome too
so when i say when i say martha doesn't
play by the game that's that's what i
mean like that's what i mean about she's
not even in the arena that we would call
any sort of normal way of living
right and for that reason she's been one
of the top three most influential people
in my entire life
you're like martha do we go left left
right or straight she's like we go up
you're like what how did how do we do
that
that's incredible
let's talk about the
integrity check
that
sternum to naval area will have to come
up with some sort of premium like
label that makes it a little easier to
i think
when you do say an integrity check and i
had read that
when reya was sick for instance you
began deleting or archiving emails
without responding as a bit of a treat
to yourself and
okay deleting goodbye
and
when you
say now
check in with yourself and
decide to say no to something let's just
to make it easy or make it concrete via
email you get an invitation
from a friend you do actually really
like with something that could plausibly
advance your career or be fun but you
check in with yourself and it's like no
this isn't a yes
how do you phrase your nose or declines
do you have any particular
go-to language that you like to use i
just want to make sure everybody knows
that this is not easy
i don't want to have any illusions for
anybody that this is simple and the
closer the relationship the harder it is
the closer and more intimately i'm
involved with somebody the more stakes
there are for me and the harder it is
for me to tell the truth and that feels
like it should be
you know there's a paradox you know the
people you love the most should be the
people that you are able to be the most
honest with
well no because they're the people who
you want to hurt the least and so that's
that's where it's really really hard
so
there's a couple layers of it right so
if it's somebody
i now treat my inbox like it's my home
because i think it's an extension of my
home so if somebody walks into my home
uninvited
and announces themselves and doesn't say
how they got a key
and asks for something i delete that
email and i will delete that email even
if they are a producer for
good morning america
you know i'm like i'm i'm just like i
didn't invite you in
there are proper channels you know what
they are um i don't know how you got my
personal email and i just delete it and
if i feel a sense in my sternum of
offense
of feeling like this person has taken a
liberty
i don't believe that i owe them anything
i don't believe that i owe them anything
any more than if i came down to my
kitchen and saw people sitting at my
table who i didn't know eating breakfast
i wouldn't believe that i owed to make
them a cup of coffee
i'd be like get out of my house like
you're not supposed to be here and i
don't think i even owe them i don't even
think i owe them a polite response i owe
them nothing i i didn't ask you to come
into my house i don't owe you anything
so that's the easiest those are ones are
easy and i now treat myself to doing
that i mean i do that every day i clear
my inbox out very quickly that way and
then it's very i i'm entertained when
they come back later and they're like
just circling back and i'm like yeah
just deleting you again
circle back as many times as you want
you are not coming in so that's simple
if it's just bumping this up because i
know you
yeah i'm just bumping you back and i'm
just it's like whack-a-moles it's like i
can do this all day delete delete delete
if it's somebody who
i care about
if it's something that i'm that i that
i'm interested in but i'm just not
going
to do it because i don't want to
i will write back and say thank you so
much i'm really honored that you invited
me to this but i'm not going to be able
to do this at this time and i don't feel
i need to give a reason i think a simple
no is
really really good and the reason
sometimes
the reason it's good not to give an
explanation
is that if that person is an expert
manipulator as many of us are that
explanation will not suffice so it won't
matter what you give as an explanation
because they can come back and be like
well we can do it by audio you know or
we can do oh if you're oh well we can do
it a different weekend just
no and i learned a lot about this from
my teacher byron katie who who teaches
an amazing thing called the school for
the work
that's a whole she's a whole another um
another being who's not not at all
living by the rules extraterrestrial for
she is extraterrestrial she is not she
is
the only fully enlightened human being i
can i believe i have ever met and as
such she does not have any trouble
saying an honest yes and an honest no to
people and just just just to underscore
that because i did a an in-person
training with her i mean literally
no
hesitation
no
struggle
no
conflict
it's none it's bizarre uh and just
mesmerizing to watch and she loves you
and she loves you there's also no
hostility so um
somebody come up to her somebody came up
to her to vent handed her a book that
they'd written which people do to me all
the time too so i really marveled at
this and they said they said i wrote
this and i want to share it with you and
she said oh sweetheart i'm never going
to read that
true it's just true i'm never going to
read that and i'm like oh my god i
didn't know you could say that
right um it's so that's amazing and she
said it so lovingly like oh oh no i have
no interest in reading that
so she teaches i don't know if you did
when you took her training did you do
where she teaches a simple no
and she does a training on how to how to
give a simple no
i don't think we actually spent much
time on that so i would love to hear you
say more we worked on the emotional one
pages and the turnarounds we did a lot
on the turnarounds which is probably we
could do a whole episode just on that
but but everybody look up byron katie
that's amazing but and if you have the
means and if you have the chance to ever
take her nine day school for the work
it's the most important thing i've ever
done for myself so oh wow say that quite
simply but she has a whole day in the
nine-day school for work which is about
the simple now and the simple no is
ways to say no
and it always begins with
thank you
and there's never a but
because she feels that the word but is
very cruel and it's just an and
so it's thank you and no
[Laughter]
and that's it that's a simple no and
then if they come back you can say well
hold on just to pause for a second is
that literally the phrasing or is it
just yeah okay no yeah that's it that's
it
and it just it still makes my stomach it
cause i'm like oh my god you can't just
do that you've gotta give you've gotta
like do the dance and she's like you
don't have to do the dance
and she's the one who taught me if the
person is a good enough manipulator it
doesn't matter what you bring
they're going to manipulate it right and
and the beautiful thing about a simple
no is that it gives in in the jujitsu
game it gives somebody no weapon that
they can take and bring back at you they
can say you're being incredibly selfish
and you can say i hear that and you
might be right about that that's another
one she always says you might be right
about that
you might be right about that and no
and you just keep adding and no after
the statement so then there's i i need
you to do this i'm i'm desperate and you
say i see that i see your desperation
and no
and and one other thing she'll add is
you can say if i change my mind about
this i'll let you know and no
and
that's been a game changer for me so i
just did one last week somebody who i
have a professional relationship said i
want you to do this one hour video
interview
to promote
this thing that i'm doing and
old liz would have thought i owe her
that because she did this other thing
for me that time
and
i checked in with my
inner compass and i was like nothing in
me wants to do this
and so i just wrote back to her i said
i'm so sorry i'm not i said i'm sorry
and i'm not going to be able to do this
at this time and she wrote back and
pushed in
and said oh let me clarify i wasn't
clear about why we need it we really
need it because right now
you know it's really hard for us to sell
things because we don't have because of
covid19 and
that's why we need it and i wrote back
and said i hear you and i understand you
and know
and
it goes away they don't tend to come
back a third time
you know it really it really does
just stop
and let it sit at the no
the more words you add after that the
more entangled you get
but again i want to make clear it's
hardest closest to home and it's hardest
with family and with family i find if i
anticipate that i'm going to be asked
something
i really have to practice i really
because it's scary and i have to i have
to really practice and be like
and just practice saying
i'm not doing that right now i'm not
coming this year i'm not doing you know
and i'll say it a thousand times i'll
just go for a long walk and i'll just
practice it and practice it and practice
it because as i say the closer the
people are to the more difficult it is
hey guys this is tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that i send out every friday to
share the coolest things i've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles i'm reading books i'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that gets sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcast guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then i test them and then i share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about
if you'd like to try it out just go to
tim dot blog friday type that into your
browser tim dot blog
friday drop in your email and you'll get
the very next one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by all
form if you've been listening to this
podcast for a while you've probably
heard me talk about helix sleep and
their mattresses which i've been using
since 2017. i have two of them upstairs
from where i'm sitting at this moment
helix has gone beyond the bedroom and
started making sofas they've launched a
company called all form
a-l-l-f-o-r-m and they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores so i'm
sitting in my living room right now and
it's entirely all form furniture i've
got two chairs i've got an ottoman and i
have an l sectional couch and i'll come
back to that you can pick your fabric
they're all spill stained and scratch
resistant the soap color the color of
the legs the soap size the shape to make
sure it's perfect for you and your home
also all form arrives in just three to
seven days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i was quite astonished by how
modular and easy these things fit
together kind of like lego pieces
they've got arm chairs love seats all
the way up to an 8c sectional so there's
something for everyone you can also
start small and kind of build on top of
it if you want to get a smaller couch
and then build out on it which is
actually in a way what i did because i
can turn
my l-sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman in a matter of about 60 seconds
it's pretty rad so i mentioned i have
all these different things in this room
i use the natural leg finish which is
their lightest color and i dig it i mean
i've been using these things hours and
hours and hours every single day so
i am using what i am sharing with you
guys and if getting a sofa without
trying it in store sounds risky you
don't need to worry all form sofas are
delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping and you get 100 days
to decide if you want to keep it that's
more than three months and if you don't
love it they'll pick it up for free and
give you a full refund your sofa frame
also has a forever warranty that's
literally forever so check it out take a
look they've got all sorts of cool stuff
to choose from i was skeptical and it
actually worked it worked much better
than i could have imagined and i'm very
very happy so to find your perfect sofa
check out allform.com
tim that's a l lform.com
tim all form is offering 20 off all
orders to you my dear listeners at
allform.com
tim make sure to use the code tim at
checkout that's allforum.com
tim and use code tim at checkout
this podcast episode is brought to you
by helix sleep
sleep is super important to me in the
last few years i've come to conclude it
is the end-all be-all that all good
things
good mood good performance good
everything seem to stem from good sleep
so i've tried a lot to optimize and i've
tried pills and potions all sorts of
different mattresses you name it and the
last few years i've been sleeping on a
helix midnight luxe mattress i also have
one in the guest bedroom and feedback
from friends has always been fantastic
something that they comment on helix
sleep has a quiz takes about two minutes
to complete that matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you with helix there's a
specific mattress for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side in
like a super soft bed no problem or if
you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress that's as firm as a rock
they've got a mattress for you too helix
was selected as the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
magazine wired apartment therapy and
many others just go to helix sleep.com
tim take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10-year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights risk-free they'll even pick it up
from you if you don't love it and now my
dear listeners helix is offering up to
200 off of all mattress orders and two
free pillows at
helixsleep.com
tim these are not cheap pillows either
so getting two for free is an upgraded
deal so that's up to 200 off and two
free pillows at helix sleep dot com
slash tim that's helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep dot com slash tim for up to 200
off
so
check it out one more time helix h e l i
x sleep.com
[Applause]
you